I have to take a [ __ ] you want to take a
pause no just keep going can you keep
going I have a question yeah yeah I said
you got stabbed once what was the story
behind that you got stabbed you said he
got stabbed your body right like right
under my stomach please please set this
up so I'm like wait we just passed by
that I got stabbed a shot at the wrong
place wrong time after the club you know
like we're like everyone had their
little gangs and they start so you were
in a gang yeah you're basically your
neighborhood is you're about the people
you grew up with you're like like a
certain crew whatever and yeah it just
it just kind of just happened and you
know what I've been shot - I'd rather
get I'd rather get shot again I've been
shot at she has been shot or he stabbed
wins no I don't remember what kind of
knife was but he kept he I mean he kid
he put it in me and then I'm trying to
back out of it yeah cuz knife wasn't
that big but the gash is actually this
big know how to get him off it but he's
keeping it inside me oh his I'm trying
to get it off me so yeah you know and
then I kind of passed out and you know
welcome in hospital yeah well what part
of your body were you shot my my shin oh
that's why you don't want Bobby to get
shot in the leg no you know I don't wish
that upon anybody maybe I guess that's
just you know a bad situation you know
so you really grew up in the hood then
yeah I mean like oh this is the worst
part I didn't grow up people say you who
must have grew up in like the worst part
I was weird cuz I would go to like the
worst part to hang out just to be like I
was there then I would go you know I
remember one time falling asleep in this
neighborhood DC that like it's called
like the worst day it's considered like
the worst caught Berry Farm it's very
very early 90s there was 27 murders in
that neighborhood you know and I thought
it was so cool because I fell asleep on
the park bench with the Rolex Rolex I
you know what I always prefer to live in
an area that's a little bit that has a
hood like that's why I lived in Long
Beach for so long living and super like
like nice squeaky clean suburban areas
freak me the [ __ ] out if people aren't
on the street in the fourth of July
exploding
80s and like doing some illegal [ __ ] I
feel uncomfortable I know there's no
culture yeah and also it's like you have
company burrs that complain too much
about noise or this and that like I want
a neighborhood where I can [ __ ] you in
pick up my barbeque grill and cook
wherever the [ __ ] I want outside without
people saying oh my guys their fire
somewhere on going on next door the app
and then complaining about it you know
what I mean like I can't do that I love
the hood I miss Green Valley
what's Green Valley that's where I grew
up in a country club he's a country club
open Green Valley where arm where you
knew the neighbors the Feingold's
Feingold's right across the street right
this schmira offs we're next to us
Goldbergs yeah not to Kolhapur oh no no
no there were no gold I didn't know
Goldberg hmm so stop saying stuff like
that okay